こんにちはは経済学部のカバーだ this
塩食ってるからご紹介がありましたようにあの日君高のこっからのご連絡をいただき
まして
このような素晴らしい機会で高校生を相手に
あの
1これから離してる gi しているお話するんですけれども
i 愛すノアの魅力についてお話しできることを大変郡なっております
よろしくお願い致します
今日お話しする内容はあの歌ヒーロンの2015に11月の記載されば
リサーチャーズアイスアイスというコラムに私が書かせていただいた
gis の魅力です
まず簡単に自己紹介させていただきます
昭和の1991年に女子金を卒業しましてその後の経済学部に進学をして1995年に
卒業しました
その後で二ジソブの政策メディア研究科の修士課程に進学をしましたこの時に初めて
ag iso を使い始めて gi の楽しさに夢中になってその後はアメリカの
mit の博士かという三氏曰くをして mit の gis グループに入って研究
を致しました
そして博士部分では職住地のミスマッチと雇用の関係についての研究をしたのですが
その際に
g アイスを使ってそれまで防大は研究蓄積があったこのテーマに対しては新しい
あのしてって英軍席を設置したと言う
ことがあの女装を外にですね高く評価をいただきまして
博士過程でも劉秀博士の文書と
またアメリカの都市計画学会でスパ優秀論文が左右正博士論文賞を受賞いたしました
あのねあの新しいツールを使うと
それまでにあの
できなかったような分析を行うことができるっていうのオープン的に目
ってのを実感した軽々となりました
a その後 o 2と g アイスを使い続けているのですが
2005年にはあのアメリカの gis プロフェッショナルという資格があるのです
がそれを日本人で初めて真柴行為だしました
その子は a 高台の空間情報科学研究センター
小口癒しセンターの魔物聞かんですけれども
こちら良い子すっごくばポストドクターのいう仕事を職を得ましてすごくをしてもその
後10きょう中として作用していただけて
その後慶応の経済学部の教員に採用されて今に至っております
ko を離れて約15年間あのアメリカに行ったり
国立大学で働いて10年ぶりにここに戻ってきた
おいては毎日の嬉しくあの楽しく仕事をしております
私の次には1i3つ河童
空間社会経済研究をテーマに米学生たちたを
ケーキを楽しくしております
これがあの今年度の私のゼミの
に所属する大学生の大学生たちです
中にはの一貫校出身の学生も何人かいますので皆さんの大学に進学して
js に興味を持ちでしたら是非入選3死球を受けてください
まずあの試合人は何かについてご説明します
愛知 n 氏というのはエッジをグラフィックインフォメーションシステムつの頭文字
を取った略で努力すると
知育地理情報システムです
anju 吸い付いては様々な定義があるのですが
例えば地理空間情報を活用基本法によると小堀ズラズラズラッとこう書いてあるように
定義をされていますが犠牲に入らせるとおじいラストいうのは米誌地図と excel
を組み合わせたようなものであるそうです
まあ
なかなかあのまたを得た簡単に分かる
出来かなというふうに思います
そのようにイメージして
学術界では g ライスの最後のですがシステムでではなくて算数 a
そのうちは速くすると地域情報化膜システムではなく科学として認識されています
これというのはちゅりとしての g 情報誌してるというよりは
学分布しての愛知に情報科学として来られるようになっているためです
地レースはあの1990年代の初めが頃からチリかくや環境科学ていったような分野で
はまああの坂に使われるようになっていっぱいあったんですが
検査医学でもですねあのその後徐々にあの gis の活用が普及してきまして
こちらの桜グラフは gis を使った経済の研究に関するマケ山の研究をした学術
文献数の推移です
ご覧のようにこうだんだんこう吹いておりまして
近年はあの部分に増加傾向後印きて
gis を意識した研究が積極的に展開されるようになっております
で慶応大学に進学しますと愛知やしソフトでおそらく五軒茶屋の世界でまたも使われて
いる
アーク gis というソフトウェアを無料で使うことができます
ええ kreva の慶応大学2012人のおじぱんくじやした最後ライセンスが導入
された彼があるのですが
気を定額に入ってい潤悪事アイスとどうもあのバージョンのソフトを買うとですね個人
でカード数百万円するようなソフトですけれどもこれを無料で使えますのでぜひあの
大学に来た際にはう進学した際には
パーク g 1を使ってみてください
ん
次に gh の利点を3つご説明します
まず一つ目は空間情報の視覚化です
愛知さというのは多くの情報をわかりやすく効果的にでんかつできる
奪いたいですので現状の理解や問題の発見
分析プル全閉所に府立ます
例えばこちらの地図は公共とが公表している
町丁目単位の地震引用ロキ検討
末の中でも建物倒壊危険度というブーバーの危険とおおー
cheers で視覚化したぽんです
ええんとキュートが向上している建物倒壊危険とは
5段階の相対評価になっていまして
危険とは後に近い歩道危険性が高いことを表します
この地図では色が濃い赤色の行為ところが危険度号は危険度が高い
そんなに kina kai ところを表しています
を超えてのもとのあのーデータは excel デートなんですがそれを gis で
視覚化してみるとこのようにですね
例えば東京都の英東部や混乱
23から何
に良い危険度は比較的高い町丁目が集積している
という様子はがあります
またあの多摩地域の方に行きますとパーの危険の売却て犠飛吹い
といった傾向をパッと見ただけで見てくることがあって
こちらの桜地図はイチからしっかり
乱舞プライス市からお米3 day は p したものです
エコーしてみました o
銀座丸の内周辺や新宿周辺といったはバックシーム周辺で地下額は手術してたが来て
郊外に行くほど
あの地価が下がった
また郊外においてもたとえば吉祥寺ですとかあ
立川で言ったような場所では周辺の地域よりも比較的地価が高いということが一目で
わかります
今年あの東海された経済産業省が主体となって開発した
リースというシステムがありますこれ皆さんインターネットでの縁もがアクセスする
ことができます
地域経済分析システム
これはビッグデータを活用した
地域経済のを見える化システムです
ええええええ
地方創生のためにまあ作られたあシステムなんですが
は施設の宿時間がありませんので省きますけれども地域の色々な統計あり経済統計や
観光に関する傍系などをですね地図上でこう
イタリーグラフを見たりすることができます
ます
航空生向けのパンフレット
もうあの公開されていますのでブーブ立ああの pdf で公開されていますので a
皆さんも興味がありましたら是非阿蘇行ってみてください
gu 4海苔店その2はですね
冷やすを使うとびち情報を聞いとしていろいろなデータを統合して会囲みすることが
できます
その結果新しいエーカーを作成することができます
例えば
距離や面積中死んでいったようなものは管理だに計算できますし
ドコドコと重なるですとか言うことと ippei 距離内のどこどこ含む
いった様は空間的な1会計に基づく
様々な系作風を
またいろいろな100種類を超えるような
ジオプロセシングツールと言えるのか
実装されていますので色々な空間データの処理を行います
その結構あの新しい1位的なデータを作成してそれを
まあいろいろな経済モデルに組み込んで分析するといっていうものができます
gus 法ペン祖母山としましては
空間情報の分析が分かります
ジュースを使うとですね
空間解析やネットワーク全席
いく如何統計などいろいろな空間分式を行います
ここ ever こちらの頭はネットワーク分析の一例ですけれども
緑の点な仏教来ないの
ベリックをお金をします
でエコの各誘引局から遠投路上の400m チェーン今
ほんと頬んだ
の元気になりますけれどもそういった研究を作成して
まああの
それこの地図に加えてたとえが昼間人口やや買う人口といったようなデータと
重ね合わせるのですね
くしい
新しく郵便局を一つ作る場合にぽに設置したらよいママって言ってるなあの
判断を
判断に役立つようなあの地図を作ることができます
うん
最近あの経済学腕もですね注目されているのがは
空間統計ツールですいろいろな空間統計を行いますけれども
例えば a この左上の地図は余震の発生時間と場所の群舞方向物の
ん
でこちらのお地図は研究通報用電話番号の発信するのポップスポット分析
こちらはですねあのおっ最小値情報というまあ回帰分析をするとですね
した結果のうち9テクニカルなフレッシュなんですけどあの山さあのホットスポット
分析というを行うとまぁあの
こういった地図を見るのですねどこに新しくあの子
優雅の変数を作ればいいとかそういう判断おこう
うかスペルような地図を作ることができます
こういったのべんだからあの解析
子供モデルを向上させるようなアプローチを行うことですね探索的データ分析と言うん
ですが
エクスポの t データーがある子ですすごいたか
政策的なデータ解析で j アイスは威力を発揮します
もう一つだけ例を見せしますこれはの地理空間か重回帰分析
今の gw あるといわれるあの
分析手法の結果の一例なんですが例えばですね先ほど見せした地下を
に影響を与える要因色々ありますけれどもその内の1つに
b と c 4ヨーイ日までの距離が近に与える影響というものがあります
これをですねあの子の gwr で分析してこれで地図化すると前田を
この落としに近いあたりでは
後信州駅までの距離の勉強が大きくて郊外に行くとだんだんその以上が小さくなる
打ったようなことをあの見せることができます
以上で私のスピーチを覆いますご静聴ありがとうございまし
ございます